el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski llegó con una gran lista de
peticiones
debemos enfocarnos en las preocupaciones
de seguridad que está de primero en la
final la seguridad en bombas que creemos
está siendo ocupada por la federación
rusa también hay preocupaciones por el
mar negro y la región desde el mar de
azov en respuesta el presidente joe
biden le reiteró su apoyo total
eeuu sigue firmemente comprometido con
la soberanía y la integridad territorial
de ucrania frente a la agresión rusa y
con las aspiraciones euroatlánticas de
ucrania
el jefe de estado estadounidense anunció
además 60 millones de dólares en ayuda
militar que será usada para combatir a
los separatistas respaldados por rusia a
lo largo de la frontera con ucrania
selenski emprendió una campaña en
búsqueda de apoyo la semana pasada
celebró una cumbre en kiev para convocar
mayor presión sobre moscú
otra de sus preocupaciones el proyecto
de gasoducto nord stream 2 que conectará
directamente a rusia con alemania
costándole miles de millones de dólares
en lucrativas tarifas de tránsito pues
el gas ruso pasa actualmente por
territorio ucraniano
en julio badén abandonó la idea de
imponer sanciones para bloquear el
proyecto considerando que era demasiado
tarde ya que su construcción estaba por
terminar cuando él llegó al poder